DURBIN'S SKILLFUL LEADERSHIP.
AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD, DURING
THE CONFIRMATION PROCESS, I HAD
THE DISTINCT HONOR OF HAVING 95
PERSONAL MEETINGS WITH 97
SITTING SENATORS.
AND WE HAD SUBSTANTIVE AND
ENGAGING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT MY
APPROACH TO JUDGING AND ABOUT
THE ROLE OF JUDGES IN THE
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM WE ALL
LOVE.
AS A BRIEF ASIDE, I WILL NOTE
THAT THESE ARE SUBJECTS ABOUT
WHICH I CARE DEEPLY.
I DEDICATED MY CAREER TO PUBLIC
SERVICE BECAUSE I LOVE THIS
COUNTRY AND OUR CONSTITUTION AND
THE RIGHTS THAT MAKE US FREE.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND FROM MY MANY
YEARS OF PRACTICE AS A LEGAL
ADVOCATE, AS A TRIAL JUDGE AND
AS A JUDGE ON A COURT OF APPEALS
THAT PART OF THE GENIUS OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL FRAMEWORK OF THE
UNITED STATES IS ITS DESIGN, AND
THAT THE FRAMERS ENTRUSTED THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH WITH THE CRUCIAL
BUT LIMITED ROLE.
I HAVE ALSO SPENT THE BETTER
PART OF THE PAST DECADE HEARING
THOUSANDS OF CASES AND WRITING
HUNDREDS OF OPINIONS.
AND IN EVERY INSTANCE, I HAVE
DONE BY LEVEL BEST TO STAY IN MY
LANE AND TO REACH A RESULT THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LAW AND
WITH THE OBLIGATION TO RULE
INDEPENDENTLY WITHOUT FEAR OR
FAVOR.
I AM HUMBLED AND HONORED TO
CONTINUE IN THIS POSITION AS A
MEMBER OF THE SUPREME COURT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WORKING WITH
BRILLIANT COLLEAGUES SUPPORTING
AND DEFENDING THE CONSTITUTION
AND STEADFASTLY UPHOLDING THE
RULE OF LAW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
BUT TODAY AT THIS PODIUM, MY
MISSION IS FAR MORE MODEST.
I'M SIMPLY HERE TO GIVE MY
HEARTFELT THANKS TO THE
CATEGORIES OF FOLKS WHO ARE
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR ME BEING
HERE AT THIS MOMENT.
FIRST, OF COURSE, THERE IS MY
FAMILY.
MOM AND DAD, THANK YOU, NOT ONLY
FOR TRAVELING BACK HERE ON WHAT
SEEMS LIKE A MOMENT'S NOTICE,
BUT FOR EVERYTHING YOU HAVE DONE
AND CONTINUE TO DO FOR ME.
MY BROTHER KATAJ IS HERE AS
WELL.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AN
INSPIRATION TO ME AS A MODEL OF
PUBLIC SERVICE AND BRAVERY, AND
I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I LOVE YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
TO MY IN-LAWS AND SISTERS-IN-LAW
AND BROTHERS-IN-LAW, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LOVE AND SUPPORT.
TO MY DAUGHTERS, TALIA AND
LEILA, I BET YOU NEVER THOUGHT
YOU'D GET TO SKIP SCHOOL BY
SPENDING A DAY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THIS IS ALL PRETTY EXCITING FOR
ME AS WELL, BUT NOTHING HAS
BROUGHT ME GREATER JOY THAN
BEING YOUR MOTHER.
I LOVE YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU
HAVE DONE FOR ME OVER THESE PAST
25 YEARS OF OUR MARRIAGE.
YOU'VE DONE EVERYTHING TO
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE ME, AND IT
IS YOU WHO HAVE MADE THIS MOMENT
POSSIBLE.
YOUR STEADFAST LOVE GAVE ME THE
COURAGE TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I BELIEVED YOU
WHEN YOU SAID THAT I COULD DO
THIS, BUT NOW I DO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND FOR THAT, I'M FOREVER
GRATEFUL.
IN THE FAMILY CATEGORY, LET ME
BRIEFLY MENTION THE HUGE
EXTENDED FAMILY, BOTH PATRICK'S
AND MY OWN WHO ARE WATCHING THIS
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND
THE WORLD.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING ME.
I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH YOU PERSONALLY IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS.
MOVING ON BRIEFLY TO THE SECOND
CATEGORY OF PEOPLE THAT WARRANT
SPECIAL RECOGNITION, THOSE WHO
PROVIDED INVALUABLE SUPPORT TO
ME PROFESSIONALLY IN THE DECADES
PRIOR TO MY NOMINATION AND THE
MANY, MANY FRIENDS I HAVE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO MAKE THROUGHOUT MY
LIFE AND CAREER.
NOW I KNOW THAT EVERYONE WHO
FINDS PROFESSIONAL SUCCESS
THINKS THEY HAVE THE BEST
MENTORS, BUT I TRULY DO.
I HAD THREE INSPIRING JURISTS
FOR WHOM I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
CLERKING, JUDGE PATTY SERIS,
JUDGE BRUCE SELIA AND JUSTICE
STEPHEN BREYER.
EACH OF THEM IS AN EXCEPTIONAL
PUBLIC SERVANT, AND I COULD NOT
HAVE HAD BETTER ROLE MODELS FOR
THOUGHTFULNESS, INTEGRITY, HONOR
AND PRINCIPLE, BOTH BY WORD AND
DEED.
MY CLEERKSHIP WITH JUSTICE
BREYER IN PARTICULAR WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY GIFT, AND ONE FOR
WHICH I HAVE ONLY BECOME MORE
GRATEFUL WITH EACH PASSING YEAR.
JUSTICE BREYER'S COMMITMENT TO
AN INDEPENDENT, IMPARTIAL
JUDICIARY IS UNFLAGGING.
AND FOR HIM, THE RULE OF LAW IS
NOT NEARLY A DUTY.
IT IS HIS PASSION.
I AM DAUNTED BY THE PROSPECT OF
HAVING TO FOLLOW IN HIS
FOOTSTEPS, AND I WOULD COUNT
MYSELF LUCKY INDEED TO BE ABLE
TO DO SO WITH EVEN THE SMALLEST
AMOUNT OF HIS WISDOM, GRACE AND
JOY.
THE EXCEPTIONAL MENTORSHIP OF
THE JUDGES FOR WHOM I CLERKED
HAS PROVEN ESPECIALLY
SIGNIFICANT FOR ME DURING THIS
PAST DECADE OF MY SERVICE AS A
FEDERAL JUDGE.
AND, OF COURSE, THAT SERVICE
ITSELF HAS BEEN A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THAT, I MUST ALSO THANK
PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHO PUT HIS
FAITH IN ME BY NOMINATING ME TO
MY FIRST JUDICIAL ROLE ON THE
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THIS BRINGS ME TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND STAFF OF THE FEDERAL
DISTRICT COURT IN WASHINGTON,
D.C., AND THE D.C. CIRCUIT.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
BATTLE-TESTED FRIENDSHIP THROUGH
THE YEARS.
ALSO A SPECIAL THANKS TO ALL OF
MY LAW CLERKS, MANY OF WHOM ARE
HERE TODAY, WHO HAVE CARVED OUT
TIME AND SPACE TO ACCOMPANY ME
ON THIS PROFESSIONAL JOURNEY.
I AM ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL TO
JENNIFER GRUDA, WHO HAS BEEN BY
MY SIDE WITH NEARLY THE OUTSET
OF MY TIME ON THE BENCH AND, AS
PROMISED, HAS PROMISED NOT TO
LEAVE ME AS WE TAKE THIS LAST
BIG STEP.
TO THE MANY OTHER FRIENDS THAT I
HAVE HAD THE GREAT GOOD FORTUNE
TO HAVE MADE THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS, FROM MY NEIGHBORHOOD
GROWING UP, FROM MIAMI PALMETTO
SENIOR HIGH SCHOOL AND
ESPECIALLY THE DEBATE TEAM, FROM
MY DAYS AT HARVARD COLLEGE WHERE
I MET MY BELOVED ROOMMATES,
LISA, NINA AND ANTOINETTE.
THEY ARE TRULY MY SISTERS.
TO MY TIME AT HARVARD LAW SCHOOL
AND THE MANY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCES THAT I HAVE BEEN
BLESSED TO HAVE SINCE
GRADUATION, THANK YOU.
I HAVE TOO MANY FRIENDS TO NAME,
BUT PLEASE KNOW HOW MUCH YOU
HAVE MEANT TO ME AND HOW MUCH I
HAVE APPRECIATED THE SMILES, THE
HUGS AND THE MANY ATTA-GIRLS
THAT HAVE PROPELLED ME FORWARD
TO THIS DAY.
FINALLY, I'D LIKE TO GIVE
SPECIAL THANKS TO THE WHITE
HOUSE STAFF AND SPECIAL
ASSISTANTS WHO PROVIDED
INVALUABLE ASSISTANCE IN HELPING
ME TO NAVIGATE THE CONFIRMATION
PROCESS.
MY TRUSTED SHERPA, SENATOR DOUG
JONES, WAS AN ABSOLUTE GODSEND.
HE WAS AN ABSOLUTE GODSEND.
HE'S NOT ONLY THE BEST
STORYTELLER YOU'D EVER WANT TO
MEET, BUT ALSO UNBELIEVABLY
POPULAR ON THE HILL, WHICH
HELPED A LOT.
I AM ALSO STANDING HERE TODAY IN
NO SMALL PART DUE TO THE HARD
WORK OF THE BRILLIANT FOLKS WHO
INTERACT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON BEHALF
OF THE WHITE HOUSE, INCLUDING
LOUISA TERRERA, REMA, TONA BOYD,
AND MANY MORE AND ANDREW BATES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I AM ALSO PARTICULARLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE AWE-INSPIRING LEADERSHIP
OF WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DANA
REMUS.
PAIGE HARWIG.
WHERE IS PAIGE?
AND RON KLAIN.
THEY LED AN EXTRAORDINARILY
TALENTED TEAM OF WHITE HOUSE
STAFFERS IN THE HERCULEAN EFFORT
THAT WAS REQUIRED TO ENSURE THAT
I WAS WELL PREPARED FOR THE
RIGORS OF THIS PROCESS AND IN
RECORD TIME.
THANK YOU ALL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU, AS WELL, TO THE MANY,
MANY KIND-HEARTED PEOPLE FROM
ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY AND AROUND
THE WORLD WHO HAVE REACHED OUT
TO ME DIRECTLY IN RECENT WEEKS
WITH MESSAGES OF SUPPORT.
I HAVE SPENT YEARS TOILING AWAY
IN THE RELATIVE SOLITUDE OF MY
CHAMBERS WITH JUST MY LAW CLERKS
IN ISOLATION.
SO IT'S BEEN SOMEWHAT
OVERWHELMING IN A GOOD WAY, TO
RECENTLY BE FLOODED WITH
THOUSANDS OF NOTES AND CARDS AND
PHOTOS EXPRESSING JUST HOW MUCH
THIS MOMENT MEANS TO SO MANY
PEOPLE.
THE NOTES THAT I'VE RECEIVED
FROM CHILDREN ARE PARTICULARLY
CUTE AND ESPECIALLY MEANINGFUL.
BECAUSE MORE THAN ANYTHING, THEY
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE HOPE AND
PROMISE OF AMERICA.
IT HAS TAKEN 232 YEARS AND 115
PRIOR APPOINTMENTS FOR A BLACK
WOMAN TO BE SELECTED TO SERVE ON
THE SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
BUT WE HAVE MADE IT.
WE'VE MADE IT.
ALL OF US.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND OUR CHILDREN ARE TELLING ME
THAT THEY SEE NOW MORE THAN EVER
THAT HERE IN AMERICA, ANYTHING
IS POSSIBLE.
THEY ALSO TELL ME THAT I AM A
ROLE MODEL, WHICH I TAKE BOTH AS
AN OPPORTUNITY AND AS A HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY.
I AM FEELING UP TO THE TASK,
PRIMARILY BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I
AM NOT ALONE.
I AM STANDING ON THE SHOULDERS
OF MY OWN ROLE MODELS,
GENERATIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
NEVER HAD ANYTHING CLOSE TO THIS
KIND OF OPPORTUNITY, BUT WHO GOT
UP EVERY DAY AND WENT TO WORK
BELIEVING IN THE PROMISE OF
AMERICA.
SHOWING OTHERS THROUGH THEIR
DETERMINATION AND, YES, THEIR
PERSEVERANCE THAT GOOD -- GOOD
THINGS CAN BE DONE IN THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
FROM MY GRANDPARENTS ON BOTH
SIDES WHO HAD ONLY A GRADE
SCHOOL EDUCATION BUT INSTILLED
IN MY PARENTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
LEARNING, TO MY PARENTS WHO WENT
TO RACIALLY SEGREGATED SCHOOLS
GROWING UP, AND WERE THE FIRST
IN THEIR FAMILIES TO HAVE THE
CHANCE TO GO TO COLLEGE.
I AM ALSO EVER BUOYED BY THE
LEADERSHIP OF GENERATIONS PAST
WHO HELPED TO LIGHT THE WAY.
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.,
JUSTICE THURGOOD MARSHALL AND MY
PERSONAL HEROINE, JUDGE
CONSTANCE BAKER MOTLEY.
THEY AND SO MANY OTHERS DID THE
HEAVY LIFTING THAT MADE THIS DAY
POSSIBLE.
AND FOR ALL OF THE TALK OF THIS
HISTORIC NOMINATION AND NOW
CONFIRMATION, I THINK OF THEM AS
THE TRUE PATH BREAKERS.
I AM JUST THE VERY LUCKY FIRST
INHERITER OF THE DREAM OF
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO BE SURE, I HAVE WORKED HARD
TO GET TO THIS POINT IN MY
CAREER AND I HAVE NOW ACHIEVED
SOMETHING FAR BEYOND ANYTHING MY
GRANDPARENTS COULD HAVE POSSIBLY
EVER IMAGINED.
BUT NO ONE DOES THIS ON THEIR
OWN.
THE PATH WAS CLEARED FOR ME SO
THAT I MIGHT RISE TO THIS
OCCASION.
AND IN THE POETIC WORDS OF DR.
MAYA ANGELOU, I DO SO NOW WHILE
BRINGING THE GIFTS MY ANCESTORS
GAVE.
I -- I AM THE DREAM AND THE HOPE
OF A SLAVE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO AS I TAKE ON THIS NEW ROLE, I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
MOMENT IN WHICH ALL AMERICANS
CAN TAKE GREAT PRIDE.
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY TOWARD
PERFECTING OUR UNION.
IN MY FAMILY, IT TOOK JUST ONE
GENERATION TO GO FROM
SEGREGATION TO THE SUPREME COURT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND IT IS AN HONOR, THE HONOR OF
A LIFETIME FOR ME TO HAVE THIS
CHANCE TO JOIN THE COURT, TO
PROMOTE THE RULE OF LAW AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL, AND TO DO MY PART
TO CARRY OUR SHARED PROJECT OF
DEMOCRACY AND EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER LAW FORWARD INTO THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU AGAIN, MR. PRESIDENT,
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE FOR
THIS INCREDIBLE HONOR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUS